- Salman Rushdie allait prendre
la parole sur la liberté
littéraire dans l'État de
New Yo l lorsqu'il a été
poignardé au cou et à l'abdomen.
Une triste nouvelle pour D D D .
DANY LAFERRIÈRE, écrivain et
membre de l'Académie française
- C'est toujours quelque chose
plus que cela; c'est pas
seulemen homme qui est
attaqué cette fois-ci. C'est
carrément, je pouvais dire mêabt
les lettres, c'est les livres.
C'est tout l'imaginaire quié.é.s
le droit d'aller au-delà de
ce qu'on sait.
- Salman Rushdie, 75 ans, a été
depuis la parution en 1988 de
son roman intitulé
"Les Versets sataniques".
L'ayatollah Khomeny avait même e
entier à l'abattre, jugeant
son ouvrage blasphématoire à
l'égard de Mahomet. Sa tête
pour la somme de près de
3 millions $ américas.s.
"C'est quelqu'un qui a toujours
continué de porter son message
de liberté, malgré les menacesÉe
New York.
- Après l'attaque d'aujourd'hui,
l'auteur d'origine indienne a
hélicoptère, il a été opéré
d'urgence. Son assaianant
présumé a été arrêté,
mais les motifs entourantbububu.
Pendant des années,
Salman Rushdie a dû vivre
caché, et sous haute protection
poli
empêché de publier plusieurs
autres livres, dont
une autobiographie signé de
son pseudonyme, Joseph Anton.
- Entre les États-Unis et
l'Europe, Samaman Rushdie ne
faisait plus l'objet de
surveillance policière depuisIlt
retrouvé une vie presque normale
et sans relâche, il militait
pour la liberté d'expression.